Hello,
all you haymakers and hamburgers,
coffee on a Tuesday and Vlog 58
with
few exceptions.
I don't really read much contemporary
fiction.
It's been that way for awhile.
If you take a look at my bookshelf,
what you'll find is a collection of
almost exclusively classic author like
Henry James Proust.
Hugo came up now because steinbeck balls
and of course shakespeare.
Now there's an irony to this because
many of these books were assigned to me
as part of my secondary school
curriculum,
but in almost every case,
what I read look more like this than
this.
How many windows do I have over there?
In one sense,
I'm glad these books were assigned to us
because now when I actually want to read
them,
I know exactly where to look.
Actually,
I sometimes suspect that that's the
reason why they assign them to us in the
first place to map the intellectual
geography of what is important and
lasting in literature.
I mean,
what other reason could there be?
I remember rereading Hawthorne's,
the scarlet letter a few years back and
thinking whoever gave this to me when I
was 15 must have been insane to think I
had the mental acuity to process one of,
if not the premier novel in American
literature at that age.
I barely had the mental acuity to
process the matrix realities,
mo doubt,
reality,
dreams will destiny.
Now,
I use the word classic in a pretty broad
sense for me.
It can be anything from homer and
Shakespeare to whack and Philip K,
Dick Essentially I'm using as my measure
a kind of collective academic agreement
about what is great,
what is influential or pressure or
complex.
Really whatever penguin has made a
version,
but perhaps I'm wrong to let penguin be
the arbiter of what is and isn't a class
taking a more precise definition.
I've turned to the great ts Elliot who
in his essay what is a classic contends
that there are actually no classics in
all of English literature,
even such greats as Milton Shakespeare,
to whom there are perhaps no superiors
in style and maturity fail to achieve
classical status because of the language
itself.
Had not yet reached mature.
A common style writes Eliot is one which
makes us exclaimed,
not this is a man of genius using the
language,
but this realizes the genius of the
language.
We do not say this when reading
Shakespeare or Milton because we are
always conscious of the greatness of the
man and the miracles that he is
performing with the length.
Indeed Elliot holds that a universal
classic comes at the confluence of a
maturity of mind,
manners and common style that Elizabeth
and poetry,
as I've said before,
is more invented by Shakespeare then
fully realized by him that the manners
of the period were more provincial than
universal elliot points to Virgil's
Aeneid as the quintessential classic and
to Latin as the quintessential classical
language for consolidates.
The greatness of a mature predecessor
and is the common ancestor to which all
of the European languages are air.
It is by the standard of Virgil and
Latin that old modern works are judged
and it is a necessary standard for
English literature to Excel and not be
consumed by chaos while being perhaps
impossible for it to achieve.
Though we must soldier on imagining that
we can't,
it's the idea of a common style that
interests me.
Most.
Common style is something that marks a
classical period,
whether in Elliot's larger sense or in a
lowercase sense,
so to speak,
of classics within English,
poetry and prose.
It doesn't mean as Elliot says that the
best writers of such a period are
indistinguishable,
but rather that there are differences
are more subtle and refined like the
shades of tastes between superlative
wine and it is also a mark of a
classical period that the era before it
is branded with eccentricities as
writers stab in the dark towards
something not yet universal and
eccentricity to as the classical period
passes away and originality becomes more
valued than correctness.
I don't know what period we find
ourselves in today,
but eccentricities a kind of agitated
free for all seems to describe it.
This of course reflects the culture at
large.
Not that we are devoid of great authors,
but rather have great movements of a
common style and every time I sit down
to write,
I find it impossible not to aim at
classic.
Now,
maybe this suggests a Hubris in me or
maybe the fact that I'm self conscious
about it suggests a deficiency in the
period as a writer and reader in 2013,
I engage in no revolt against the
current state of English literature.
It's too heterogeneous now.
Even for that,
I only wished to navigate that old and
shamefully pass a river,
which from the mountain of homework
passes through all my heroes and me too.
I know not what?
Hey,
everybody.
Thanks for watching.
Please subscribe if you haven't already
in.
Don't forget to follow me on twitter and
tumbler links in the description.
Also,
thank you to nutty Nathan and all you
guys who supported the Tuesday thing.
We're keeping it and I'm glad you're
with me.
I'll see you guys next time.